[Musik]
okay wir sind hier am haus von michael
becker und seiner blauen cap collins
leute gesehen er hat hier ein tramp
und dann hat er sein haus von ein
bisschen auf halloween vorbereitet aber
es ist so im moment erscheint es scheint
da nicht so aus zu sein die
nachbarschaft ist jetzt nicht so
schrecklich attraktiv hause ganz gut aus
ist ein kanal r1000 schönes bot aber
hier gleich 300 mitarbeiter ist ein
großer hype ist also eine sehr studie
[Musik]
sagen ich mal mittelklasse untere
mittelklasse her weil es auch sehr
abgelegen ist und nicht gerade eine
attraktive oder teure und da sehen wir
weiter
mit dem wir mit dieser weise zu kommen
zugang zum golf von mexiko hat sich ganz
54 alles ist manipuliert hat es ist
tipptopp in ordnung also ganz
offensichtlich
der kommt der kärtner pipeline steckt
wohl hier wirkt alles ein überdachter
das macht man ganz gern in florida damit
man mit kronen
[Musik]
also das ist ein hübsches haus wie
gesagt nur die nachbarschaft ist jetzt
nicht so schnell
nein
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren